yeah okay so we just turned your hearing
on a child's first word is a precious
moment but for Joe Gina's parents when
she heard them was just as special
georgina was born severely deaf she was
6 weeks old when she got her very first
hearing aids everything maybe you said
something first and your deep voice and
she turned towards you didn't Shane then
I stirred something she turned back we'd
never seen a turn towards sound before
so it was just brilliant yeah so
emotional Georgina is now four months
and a video showing her hearing the
world around her has gone viral on
social media it's a moment of pure joy
that's had hundreds of thousands of
views as well as comments from families
with similar experiences it was great
because when she first got diagnosis
particularly we were kind of looking for
other people's stories because you want
to know that it's gonna be okay and so
table these people just bring it you
know they've been through it so it's
fantastic yeah you do you get lots of
people in their twenties that are
posting you know that have come through
that like care pathway never you know
indeed Georgina's cutting edge hearing
aids were free on the NHS with the right
support and new technology deafness is
no obstacle to development I think it's
an absolutely wonderful moment to see
her reaction to see that reaction to
sound to hearing her parents voice and
to see the connection that she makes and
how much joy that brings I think her
father said that it would like the
lights have been switched on and as
someone who's profoundly deaf myself I
can very much relate to that and how it
makes the connection into the world
around you and this is certainly one
little person who wants to be seen and
heard
Catherine impotency Sky News in
Harrogate